what's up believe nation we are live 11
happy Thursday part of my dedication to
be here with you guys on YouTube every
week answer questions be a support
system for you it's the best part of my
day be able to connect with fans kind of
one-on-one be able to help you out
today's session brought to you by my
workshop coming up in Toronto helping
thought leaders make money from their
ideas we are 75% sold-out may 23 2015 1
in my team and basically help you figure
out how to make money from your ideas be
that thought leader build a business
around it basically do what I do but for
your industry so we already have what
we've four spots left basically we got
15 spots max and that's it so hopefully
some of you guys will be there looking
forward to seeing the ones who have
already signed up let's get to some
questions guys give it to me in the live
chat I see a whole bunch of people
joining in live I love it I love it I
love it if you tagged me it's gonna be a
lot easier for me to see your questions
thank you so much okay what do we got
Brasilia hello from France you are my
number one motivator thank you for the
love Brasilia I really appreciate that
I'm Keith can you please tell me how to
change my subconscious patterns woo this
is a great one to start off on I love it
great question Ikey okay so here's the
thing it's not always subconscious most
of the time I think people default to
plain small just subconsciously most of
the time like 98% of the time you will
default to plain small subconsciously
the 2% of the time though that you're
not and you catch it it's what do you do
in those moments and so the example I
like to share is when I was walking on
the street I got earphones in I'm
listening to music and I'm Bob and I'm
dance and I'm having a great time
dancing up on the street and then as I
get to the main intersection lots of
people I start dancing small because I'm
worried about the judgement of other
people and when I notice that then I
know that I have to dance bigger I have
to conquer that limitation I have to
conquer that subconscious pattern so now
I'm dancing big on the street just
because not not to get in anybody's face
not to make
them uh you know unhappy not to violate
personal space but just for myself the
thing is how many times have I gone down
that street corner and done the same
thing without noticing that's the thing
right like how many times if I walked
down did the exact same thing dance big
in the side street and then play small
when I get to the main intersection I
think that's what most people do every
day in their life you don't catch it
so 98% of the time you don't catch it so
for the 2% what do you do you need to
train yourself to do when you can
actually catch that thing what do you
then take as your next action so because
I found myself playing small because of
the 2% of the time I caught it
now I have to do it now the next time
that that happens what am I gonna do I'm
gonna notice it more then it's not 2%
now it's 10 percent now it's 20 percent
now it's 50 percent and soon that
becomes a habit that whenever I'm on the
street corner now I don't care same
thing with these nails see my nails see
those beautiful nails how does that a
nail sign with my team and they joked
that I should do it and because of
because of my initial reaction being oh
my god fear of judgment I'm meeting
people I'm coming on live streams and I
have how long is this gonna take to come
off all of these fear of judgement of
other people not then I have to do it I
had to do it because I was uncomfortable
then I had to do it and now this isn't
necessarily what I'm gonna do ongoing I
don't need to choose to express myself
by putting nail polish on but I'm
conquering that little limitation so the
next time something twigs in me that
could be subconscious that I'm gonna
play small because of somebody else's
judgments opinions expectations I won't
because I'm training myself it's not
that go off and do big things it's in
these little things in these micro
moments that if you start training
yourself to do it when you do catch it
in those two percent of the moments then
you become more self-aware then you stop
living small by default the second bit
of advice I know we're going long on
this but it's such an important question
the second thing I recommend is the
behavior that you want to change the
subconscious pattern that you want to
change to invite the people around you
to call you out on the things that
you're doing when you're doing it so
you know if it's fear of judgement of
other people whenever you make a comment
about you're scared to do something
because if somebody else is gonna judge
you your friends the five closest people
to you need to call you out I do it for
complaining if you catch me complaining
I told my wife I told my team I told the
people around me if you ever catch me
complaining call me out and say Evan
you're complaining you're complaining
stop it right and Nina's pretty good at
it gr Isis pretty good at the people on
my team call me out on it and I like it
I want it right I missed it it's still
subconscious now I'm complaining not a
huge chunk of the time write it but it's
still that 5% of the time or 2% of the
time you know I still want to squash
that and so if you can train the people
around you to call you well on the thing
that's subconscious pattern that you
want to fix then it really helps so
those two things fix the micro right the
the 2% of the times what you do because
if you don't if you do not make that
shift if I go to the street corner and I
don't start dates and big and I play
small now consciously you're consciously
playing small then you set yourself way
way way way way way back you just
reinforce that really small thinking and
that subconscious pattern will just get
stronger and stronger and so the 2% of
time you catch it you have to do
something about it and then invite five
closest people in your life to call you
out on the behavior when they see it I
love it amazing question thank you for
the love I love it yes Thursday with
believe nation what do we got we got we
got we got questions crazy cool
creations what is the hardest day job
what is the hardest job day-to-day of an
entrepreneur what is the hardest job
day-to-day of an entrepreneur I think
for most people they're doing something
that they don't have a passion for and
so that becomes a massive challenge I
think most entrepreneurs are just
looking for an opportunity they open up
a magazine and they see the top ten
businesses to make money within 2018 and
they go after that instead of actually
tapping into thing that they love so if
you are doing work that you hate you
will lose period end of story you will
lose people who love doing that thing
will crush you every day of the week and
so I think that's the biggest mistake
that a lot of entrepreneurs are made
if you if you are if you have found a
thing that you love when you are doing
it the hardest day-to-day job I think is
just managing your motivation I think so
often the entrepreneurs we start and
stop and start and stop and we're
motivated one day and then not for four
days and I'm motivated again and then
not for eight days and you have these
massive spurts of energy and momentum
and believe and confidence and boldness
and then and then where'd you go you
fell off like goodbye the motivation is
gone and so it's hard when there's no
boss above you it's hard when you are
only accountable to yourself a lot of
people are not used to being only
accountable to their selves you know we
grow up we have parents who tell us what
to do we go to school they tell us what
to do we have a boss he tell us what to
do and now you're all on your own what
are you gonna do and so people have a
hard time with that
and so finding the thing that gets you
motivated whatever that thing is
watching the video reading the book
listen to podcasts going to meet people
hanging on coffee shop like whatever the
thing is it gets you motivated and
making that part of your daily routine
is super important because I think most
people do not have the motivation I feel
like I'm talking really quick
I'm really excited this is great I
missed you guys last week right did I
did I do this last week I don't know
it's been a it's been a long crazy week
but I am pumped to be here next Aman
tag-me guys I see a ton of chatter
coming in tag me it's a lot easier for
me to see Evan have you tried any method
stated in the book Think and Grow Rich
thinking Grow Rich is it worth it
I like thinking Grow Rich a lot of
people that I know use that book as an
annual tradition they read through the
book they get more ideas I think just
the idea of for me it's a book about
belief it's a book of if you can think
of something and you can visualize it
and you believe that you can do it then
aha you can go off and actually do it
and your brain starts to find ways to
make it happen
I think people too often just look for
reasons why they can't win I think so
many people just live in that world of
why you can't win even you yourself like
you want to be the next whatever you
want to be a car maker you want to be a
youtuber you want to be an author and
then the default mechanism is well I
can't do that because I don't have the
education and I don't have the team but
I don't know the resources and I don't I
don't I don't I don't I
I don't you live in a land of I don't
wear one of the great concepts for that
book is you now shift it to how can i
when you start actually visualizing
yourself being that person your brain
sets a shift of finding instead of the
99 ways that it's not gonna work the one
way that it will and as soon as you
start shifting your mind to what's the
one way that this is actually gonna work
using the talent resources capabilities
that I currently have right now man
that's when life starts to open up and
so if you can shift yourself from that
perspective of here's why I can't
looking for the reasons why it will
never work to here's why I will here's
how I can then then you start the win
and so but for all of this like what was
the question let me go back was the
question have you tried any method
stated in the thinking book thinking
we're rich and is it worth it if if you
are thinking about reading the book like
thinking Grow Rich just go read it what
are you waiting for stop thinking about
it guy stop thinking about this stuff
you have an idea just go do it how long
does it take you to go to a bookstore
and just open up the book and read a
couple pages and see does it hit does it
click does it resonate with you it
doesn't matter what my opinion is on
this just go and do it start see if you
like it see if you are enjoying it so
many people write in and say what do you
think about this industry or this
business or what should I do it doesn't
matter what I think go and do it and try
and see what you think so if there's a
book that you want to read just go pick
up the book and try it what's the worst
case scenario all of this time that
you're spending this is the biggest
thing you're wasting time
this time thinking about it and
pondering and wondering and then maybe
next we can get to it or next month or
next year just do it this is such a
small thing it's so easy to do just go
pick up the book you don't have to buy
it yet just go to the go to the library
go to the bookstore and read a couple
pages and see if you like it as soon as
you start thinking about something this
is so important for entrepreneurs as
soon you start thinking about something
find the smallest possible way to
actually go out and do you want to be a
youtuber great start get your phone out
and make a video
you want to learn piano start
everything's gonna suck that's okay just
start find a way to start stop thinking
stop thinking stop thinking and just get
it out very excited today I missed you
guys this is good
okay next pollyanna how do you decide on
something to pursue when you're when you
are very interest and only know that you
want to foster a flexible lifestyle so
Pollyanna your genius will come by
combining the end instead of thinking
this or this you will win by doing both
find the way to win it doing both if you
only pick one so you know if you love
personal training and you love being a
vegetarian right be the personal trainer
for vegetarians mix it because if all
you try to do is be a personal trainer
you're gonna lose
because the people who love just being a
personal trainer will crush you and
you'll always feel this hole in your
heart and this pull to do something else
and the same thing if you're just go in
and help people be vegetarians it's
gonna be the same thing you will get
crushed at people who love doing just
that and you'll always feel this pole in
this other direction and so you need to
figure out how can you combine those two
things together the lifestyle thing like
if you want to be an entrepreneur
there's gonna be a lot of work do not be
an entrepreneur just for the lifestyle
because the lifestyle is is a crime you
have to enjoy the work that you're doing
if it's a part-time thing or something
you want to evolve to great but like I
believe in loving the work that you're
doing and so that like if that's your
goal to be an entrepreneur don't make it
I want to be an entrepreneur just for
the lifestyle cuz because the lifestyle
is not fantastic unless you love the
work and to find the things the two
things or three things that you love
doing and find a way to mash them
together because that's hell that's how
you will not be copied that's how you
will always win that's your competitive
advantage those two or three things that
you may not be the best in any of them
but you're the best at combining them
that's how you will win please please
please please think about it and and
look for the yes look for the how can I
make this happen because there's um
million noes a million reasons why you
can never combine these three things
together look for the one way that will
work you your brain towards that and
that's how you're gonna win good luck
next pronoun I'm a teenager I have an
awesome plan but whenever I work but
whenever I work for it I cannot focus on
my study what should I do
I'm confused you know we've talked a lot
about education on the stream before it
really depends on what your what you're
trying to go and achieve education
especially looking at a college level is
great if you're trying to get a job not
that handy if you want to be an
entrepreneur so it's a fantastic back-up
plan that I think people should have I
don't think you need to put all your
cards in to put all your eggs into one
basket put all your cards on the table
at once unless you absolutely know that
you want to be an entrepreneur and
there's no other option for you I think
it's great having a back-up plan what I
would do is just schedule it in like you
think this is hard now trying to
schedule study and and work just to
machen when you get older imagine when
you have parents that you need to look
after much when you get married imagine
when you have kids like this is easy
stop saying this is hard this is not
hard you you are living an easy life
right now and if you think this is hard
then you will not keep a bowl of harder
things period whatever France for all
you guys listen whatever big challenge
is so impossible that's in front of you
if you tell yourself that this is
impossible this is so hard I can't
figure this out then you are not capable
of greater things you will always be
stuck dealing with these small problems
this is easy life is easy for you right
now let that sink in and the way to
solve that problem is just scheduling
you have to go to class that's during
set times you have to study set times
Friday night your study and Thursday
night your studying when they Tuesday
Wednesday working on your business
whatever it is you schedule all that
stuff in and then from there you work
your plan and you just execute and if
it's not quite the right schedule you
adjust but it's gonna get a whole lot
harder once you have a team once you
really build something big once you look
after your parents once you have more
family commitments it's gonna get a lot
harder this is your time this is easy
this is the warm-up you're capable of
much greater things Salima in your
opinion how long does it take the bill
to monetize from a brand this
this I'm super passionate about I'm
excited for the people coming to Toronto
because is what we're gonna basically be
talking about how do you build a
personal brain and monetize it it
depends on a couple things it depends on
one how good you are do you have the
talent do you have the skills if you're
coming out and making videos are you
good on camera have you done it before
your message is it important enough
is there enough confidence behind it do
people gravitate towards what you're
saying as an example we've made a couple
videos on a guy named gora Gopal das I'd
never heard of him he's this Indian monk
never heard of him before and somebody
suggested we do him so we put it up boom
he takes off so it's exploding and his
message is just so easy to understand he
tells amazing stories the challenge is
most people can't play at that level so
if nobody knew who go or Gopal das was
and we made a video on him and they
watched it all the way through it's like
who is this guy is amazing where you
might have been around for 10 years but
still suck at delivering a message and
your stories are still not fantastic and
so really depends on you your ability
your ability to one have an opinion that
is meaningful to be seen something that
moves people and three work on your
skills to be able to deliver that
message consistently I am NOT a natural
storyteller I am NOT a naturally
extroverted person I'm not great at
making videos go back to my channel when
I started I was nervous I was terrible I
sucked it's through 6,000 videos and I
start getting better a little bit you
better gets better at something if you
practice it 6,000 times and so really
it's gonna come down to how good you are
at having content that moves people
towards taking some kind of action
because if you're great you'll make
money really quickly and if you suck
then you have to work on your skills to
be able to get there it's not a great
answer but that's what happens with that
question next Zak what do you do what do
you do to get motivated and inspired so
I think what I do is not as important as
what you should do I think I can tell
you my my path but more importantly if
you grow what your path is
here's what I do every morning I wake up
I go to the bathroom I'm tired you know
I mean I have had enough sleep today was
particularly difficult today I don't
because of my workout yesterday or
something just the energy was a lot
harder to get up I was really hungry I I
was on the bike today and really
struggling to get through it but the way
yet I wake up get up go to the bathroom
wipe the sleep is out of my eyes read
one page to my book the top ten rows a
success then then I record a message on
my phone and that goes to my Instagram
Twitter snapchat and in that process I
get primed for the day so for me the
reason why I wrote that book is if you
read to genius ideas from some of the
people who've changed the world who are
just playing on a bigger level than you
it pulls you up it pulls you into it
right it takes two minutes to read
through and then what I love doing is I
love sharing like I'm I'm
there's nobody here today you know it's
easy to get low I love being with you as
part of my commitment here I'm I'm the
fire is real because I love being around
you guys and so for me sharing a message
aims me up more so I read to I read one
page from the book I get a thought I
make a video and in that process that
takes all in I don't know five to ten
minutes all in after that I'm ready to
go from there get on the bike come up
have a shower and then get ready for
whatever I'm doing for that day you know
I love being around successful big
thinking game-changing entrepreneurs
that drives me nuts that drives me I'm
like in a good way I love it that fires
me up figure out what it is for you and
the thing is you already know you
already know when you've been fired up
you already know what's got you feeling
bold and courageous now just do that
every day and it's hard to do the same
thing if I read the same one-page every
day I wouldn't get fired up if I watch
the same Steve Jobs video every day I
wouldn't get fired up you need a
consistent source that was the goal with
this book I paid today you've got
hundreds of pages in there
you're not going run out of content
right and if you revisit it a year later
that's okay the message will still be
fresh and new or my videos right like
watching a channel the goal of having a
channel of having three videos a day is
not to not to make you watch every video
I don't need you
to watch every video in the channel
watch the ones that you need for
yourself but in coming back there's
always gonna be something new for you if
you if watching videos is a thing for
you then here's a source and whether
it's my channel or or Gary's or Tom's or
grants or ties or whoever in the space
really speaks to you great like watch
that because there's consistent content
every day that's coming out that can get
you motivated so most important is you
already know you already know the thing
that gets you feeling motivated and
excited and if you can find a consistent
source for that then feed that into your
morning routine and if you did that and
you were bold every single morning your
life will be on a just totally different
trajectory you will not recognize your
life when you're from today
next Ravi Shankar how to hang the
frustration I smile I smile at
frustration I think it's my chance to be
able to to win to prove to myself what
I'm capable of I mean uh I made a video
on Instagram this morning when I was on
the bike I'm getting on the bike I'm
supposed to do 350 calories on the bike
that takes me about 35 minutes to go
through and do I'm less than a third of
the way through and my legs are burning
burning burning normally I can I can
breeze through 35 minutes no problem
still tons of energy at the end I was
burning at 10 minutes through like I
wanted to quit my legs are on fire I
don't know how I'm gonna get the energy
to do this and as soon as I catch it
here's what I do I smile like this is my
chance this is my moment this is my my
time to be able to show my self what I'm
capable of because it's easy when it's
easy when it's easy if I'm if I only
have to do ten minutes it's easy or when
I have lots of energy that day it's
really easy right it's easy to win a
race against three-year-olds it's just
easy but when it's hard when you're
frustrated when you don't have energy
when you're angry
this is your chance this is your chance
to see what you're actually made up and
this is this now becomes so important to
the identity building for yourself
it's so critical because what happens if
I quit today if I'm on the bike and I
want to do 350 calories that's my goal
35 minutes on the bike if I quit early
I've just signaled to
that when things get hard when things
are frustrated when I don't have energy
I play small I quit and that's okay
where if I muscle through it and say I'm
gonna make this happen no matter what
then by the time I get to the end of 35
minutes which was amazing it's like yes
I did it right it's like now you're
building the muscle now you can't do
that every single day every single day
is digging deep into the reserves that's
gonna be a really strong challenge for
you if every day you woke up and you're
just massively frustrated with the world
and what was happening it's it's hard to
keep that consistent it's hard to keep
the energy level high but ideally what
you have is you have a baseline and if
you have to dip into it if things are
really frustrating or slow for you I
just use that as a chance to smile I
smile at it I recognize a problem I
smile it and like this right now this is
my chance this is my chance to show
myself in the world what I'm capable of
my chance to build some muscles and if
you get through it if you don't succumb
if you succumb to the frustration you're
teaching yourself I always succumb the
frustration and it's gonna be hard if
you the next time but if you if you if
you plow through it you blast through
that frustration teaching yourself when
I get frustrated I can still win and I
grow through it and that becomes your
identity and then it's just so much more
fulfilling do it guys it's so important
okay next
Salima how do you get better how how did
you better you're speaking and video
making skills apart from practice apart
from the most important thing how did I
get better
apart from practice it's modeling
success it's looking at people that we
look up to and trying to understand
their style understand what makes them
tick understand what lessons you can
pull from them to make your thing better
I also got mentored as part of sort of
an agent in New York and part of the
training with him was media training and
for a year and a half I worked with a
media coach through him that I would
watch a video and I would get better you
know I paid $10,000 to that training
that's part of what I'm doing in Toronto
like I'm taking the training that I
learned and bringing it to you guys
people to
help you guys get better and what you're
doing and so practice is great but
practicing the same thing without
understanding if it's working or not
is not practicing the wrong thing
consistently will just make you better
doing the wrong thing so when I practice
I look back at the content and look back
and see did I get better where do I want
to improve how could this be better even
now before I go and record an N spresso
video for example I'll watch my old and
stressful video and I'll look for points
like could I have done better could this
be strong or could this has been a
little bit you know improved and if I
can't come up with ideas that's a
problem if I look at my video and I say
that was perfect that's a problem means
I don't know how to fix it if I can
think of how to fix it and make it
better than then there's still a room if
I'm at my ceiling already that's when
you need to bring in outside people who
can say no you actually suck like you
need to get here and in a good way right
if I don't know how to fix what I'm
doing then there's no way for me to grow
and I know I'm not the best I know I'm
nowhere close to where I could
potentially go so practice like practice
is important don't disrespect the
practice and then from there model of
success and get Mentors next Michael do
you think it's good for me to restart my
channel and throw out the so called
YouTube rules and social numbers that is
killing my passion and purpose this is
the problem Michael
if if your passion and purpose is tied
to a result you're gonna lose always
I'll say it again if your passion and
purpose is tied to a result you're going
to lose always if you're tying your
passion to how many views you get on
YouTube you're gonna lose now results
are important
making money is important if your
whatever the metrics are in your
industry are gonna be important but it
can never be the number one thing never
ever if it's the number one thing you
lose you will never win you've got to
enjoy the process you have to enjoy the
work so should you restart your youtube
channel I don't know do you enjoy making
YouTube videos if you do then keep going
if you don't quit now like you should
have quit sooner move on to something
else that you are passionate about you
will get crushed or the people who love
that job they love that word
and so I love making videos I love
connecting with my audience I love I
love doing this I love helping
entrepreneurs I love it I love it I love
it I love it I do it you know I started
as new thing Instagram wife I'm
following my fans and when they go on
life I'm trying to hop onto their
livestream and so I'm sitting there like
refreshing refresh like when somebody
gonna good luck I'm certainly gonna go
live I want to join you I want to join
you I love this and that's something
that's hard to replicate you can't
replicate that strategy because you
won't stick with it long enough because
you don't love it as much so that's why
I'm not worried about Evan Carmichael
copycats and impersonators I just do my
thing and so your ultimate success in
any kind of business will be what you
love doing with what there's a market
for where the audience is and so yes the
results are going to be important you're
not just shutting a blind eye to the to
the results but if your passion is tied
to hitting numbers you're gonna lose
forever and always so you've got to
figure out do you love the process of
making videos of making content is it
going to be just a hobby that you do for
yourself yes or no if you want it to
turn into a business then yes the
numbers are gonna tie in making money is
gonna tie in but it's never the number
one thing it can't be making money
hitting numbers winning awards is
amazing great feeling it allows you to
go off and do even better things but as
if that's your number one you lose so
some self-awareness Michael figure that
out for yourself and good luck men I
want you to win next Priscilla
can you share some tips on how to how to
convince a bigger company to buy or
innovation which can change lies in
Africa so listen a couple things here
one the ID alone is not enough you have
to be able to execute whatever idea that
you have unless you have the patent for
it the idea is not enough there's so
many like I have so many ideas that
coca-cola could use to change lives in
Africa or IBM or Tesla or McDonald's it
doesn't mean that they're gonna pay me
to do that and so just the idea without
like if you just bring them the idea and
then
to do all the work you're not getting
paid because even if you do bring the
idea and they love it
if they haven't thought about it and
don't assume they haven't thought about
it yet then they're gonna turn to their
team and say okay how can we do this
they're not they don't want to pay you
so the way to protect yourself is one
you have the patent on the idea or two
you can actually help the execution like
you can bring something to McDonald's a
coca-cola or Tesla or whoever to
actually help make that idea happen not
just consulting and ideas but execution
make it happen for them so when I work
with big companies they come to me for
ideas great but I'm gonna help them do
it
I work with sage as an example Stephen
Kelly comes on once a month we do a
hangout for you guys answering questions
and in that process I'm not just helping
him with ideas and what stage can do I'm
exposing him to my audience I'm helping
him execute he wants to spread his
mission entrepreneurs I'm a great person
to do that with and so you have to
figure out one if it's only the idea you
are sunk unless you have the patent and
two how do you help them actually
execute on the idea start building
momentum as soon as possible don't just
wait on some big company to come and
hand you a paycheck and assume that that
like that's all you need build momentum
build momentum start doing it start
doing it start doing it as soon as
possible
next up Hugo Hugo $5 super chat thank
you for the love man next coffee is on
you
I appreciate that Hugo my family thinks
I'm crazy for giving Amazon selling a
second chance after feeling once before
is the way of the entrepreneur lonely
like that
you know it can be you have to decide at
what point if you want to live your life
or your family versions of your life
that's it are you trying to live Hugo's
life or you're trying to live Hugo's
parents life and listen family most of
the time most of the time not always but
most of the time it's out of love they
want you to win right they don't want to
see you hurt yourself they don't want to
see you be unsuccessful they want you to
win the problem is the way that they see
winning is through their eyes right like
your dad is a pharmacist and so they
think that
you should be a pharmacist because
that's how you're gonna be safe and
secure because that's how he won
chances are you don't want the same
things as your parents do you don't want
the same things as your family does and
so if you can first just for empathy
just to understand that chances are they
want you to win and the the execution
sucks but it's coming from a place of
love already helps ease some of the
burden and frustration if you just have
parents who hate you well that just
sucks and and you know you want to get
as far away from them as possible
second adjust your thoughts run failure
look at look at Jeff Bezos you love
Amazon look at Jeff Bezos how many times
he has failed and his views on failure
failure is just part of the process you
will fail you will fail you a failure
you'll failure fail you'll feel a lot
them the people who you love and look up
to and respect the most failed the most
period so you failed one time dude
that's nothing you failed one time and
then you're gonna throw in the towel
that's what a lot of people do they have
an idea they want to take a shot they
fail and then that's it now they can't
be an entrepreneur and so they're gonna
go off and lay up the next 50 years of
their life working for somebody else and
hating their existence that's the most
people do that's not that's not a
healthy plant expect to fail expect to
suck just try to keep your feel small
don't don't take one huge shot and you
mortgage your house and all of your
savings and if this doesn't work you're
screwed lots of small failures try try
try try try try ultimately you're gonna
win but you have to stick with it long
enough and then the lonely entrepreneur
path you know if you if you stop
spending as much time with your parents
and your family if you stop spending
time around people who are bringing you
down or at least not talk to them about
business you know you can spend time
with your parents but not talk to me
what you're doing because you know that
it's just gonna lead to an argument
you're cutting out the negative in your
life but now what are you gonna fill it
with entrepreneurship doesn't have to be
massively lonely you can surround
yourself with members of belief nation
you can surround yourself with other
entrepreneurs who bring you up who lift
your spirits
there's something that just being around
other entrepreneurs
is amazing like it gives you energy it
gives you hope it gives you more believe
it's part of why the thing in Toronto
that I'm doing I want I want 15 people
so that I want to infect you and I want
you to be around other people as well
who want the same thing because being
around like-minded people is such a huge
shot of adrenaline and so finding people
whether it's online or offline that you
can connect with that you can be around
that lifts you up that make you feel
that it's possible I think is really
helpful so it doesn't have to be
massively lonely all the time I think it
I think it's your self awareness how
much do you need for yourself I don't
really need that as an example being
super introverted I don't need to be
around people to get lots of energy I
love this part like Thursday's my
public-facing day and I got a day of
interviews and hangouts and podcasts and
all that kind of stuff but I don't need
to be around people
in fact if I'm always around people
it'll it'll suck my energy so
understanding how much you need that for
yourself and you don't have to default
to there is no option I'm going to be
lonely my entire life
you can definitely combat that if you
want to but it just may not be from your
parents next Michael how do I self
punish and praise myself I know it's
important but how great question I think
I think the most successful
entrepreneurs have a foot in both world
of praise and of punishment or just
punishment I think more of being hard on
themselves expecting more be able to do
more from themselves I think that's I
think it's super common I think what you
have to learn to do is kick yourself
forward and not down this is the hardest
thing so if you are looking at a hero of
yours you're looking at Elon Musk for
example and say wow this guy is doing
amazing things or Steve Jobs or Oprah
Winfrey or whoever your hero is what
ends up happening a lot of times is
people look at those people and they say
wow Elon is just next-level genius I'm
never gonna be able to do something like
him and you use that huge success story
to beat yourself down and you will never
be successful I came and so why even try
that's what a lot of people fall into
where what you can do is use that as
inspiration to say what's amazing when
Elon Musk is doing and I'm gonna use
that because all the people around me
suck and aren't doing anything big I'm
gonna use that as motivation to go off
and do something bigger for myself I
think it's really important that you are
critical of yourself and that you look
for ways to improve and it's all based
on a place of self-love so if I look at
my youtube channel as an example this is
a practical example I went to this event
last year called climber con going back
this year in LA Palm Springs and I'm
having dinner with these creators about
we're all around you know a couple
hundred thousand in in subscribers at
that time and I'm really hard on myself
like I need to make better content I'm
you know I'm doing three times a day I
need better content I need to be better
on camera I'm not good enough yet I need
to improve my editing I need to prove my
research every every aspect of my videos
need to get better for me to hit my goal
you know I deserve to be where I'm at
but I don't deserve to be higher up
because I need to hit my goal and
they're like wow you're so hard on
yourself man why are you so hard you
know you're doing a great job you
shouldn't be that rough I'm like what
are you talking about I my channel is
awesome I should win a Nobel Prize for
my channel it's the best thing on
YouTube I think my channel is the best
thing on YouTube I love it
and so it's living in both worlds right
it's that I love everything that I do
and I think is amazing ain't it sucks
and needs to get better and so maybe on
Sundays you need a little bit more of
one side than the other but but I try to
live in those worlds and I try to do
that for the people on my team as well
if I look at Alex from Toronto Dane
salsa if he comes in he said he had a
great night of tea chains like great
awesome how can it be better right or if
I'm visiting the class he said I thought
that went really well it's like yeah I
was okay but you can you can don't don't
set over here you could be way up here
but if you had a really rough night and
it's super bad everything went terrible
there's no point in adding on the whips
the
because he's not gonna hear it's not
gonna help him he needs to be brought
back up to a place of self-love before
he can ever hear the message of
improvement and so I think being the
person that holds yourself to a higher
standard and then having people around
you who hold you to a higher standard
from a place of love because I know you
can do it as opposed to you suck and
you're never gonna get there
is really really important next Dave I'd
like to see Lou Holtz top ten this is
not the place for top ten request if
you're a fan of the channel you know
check the description any video you can
go cast your requests on a request line
Sofia
what to do when you feel stuck in life
and you're not able to do anything and
just go with the flow I think if you are
stuck in life the first thing you want
to do is figure out what your most
important core value is that's why I
wrote the book your one-word understand
what your most important core value is
because chances are you are doing a lot
of things in life that are against what
you actually believe in and staying for
and until you have the self-awareness to
know what your most important core value
is it's really hard to find a life that
that will then be aligned but then it
becomes easy once you have the path when
you have the compass when you have the
road map everything becomes a lot easier
so I would put that as my most immediate
first step figure out your most
important core value whether whether
you're reading my book or another book
or watching a different video the
understanding the awareness to know what
you stand for is a human being I think
has to be the foundational move to get
unstuck next I would look at saying yes
to as many things as possible I believe
we have windows of opportunities through
life multiple windows of opportunities
through life and if you're stuck for too
long then you don't see the next window
and you can't jump through it but with
every window of opportunity that comes
up you also have a limited amount of
time to make it work I look at YouTube
as an example for me this is a limited
window for me I don't I don't know if
I'll still be doing YouTube in 20 years
right YouTube mean I have me around in
20 years so give me something much
bigger and so this might be a three year
window or five year window a 7 year
window and so I want to push as hard as
I can to make the biggest impact
possible while that window is still open
for me and so to find your next window
you don't find it sitting on the couch
you don't find it just brainstorming you
got to get out and do you say yes you
know if you're trying to find what your
favorite food is you don't try you don't
figure it out by sitting on the couch
looking at pictures of food you go won't
you taste it right like Oh sushi that's
cool that tastes delicious you won't
know what it tastes like just by looking
at a picture I think that's what most
people do they try to brainstorm their
way to find what the thing is that they
love and that's not the way to do it you
just say yes expect everything to suck
and say yes and and try and the acid
test is not did I love this and this is
my next passion it's do I want to go
back so try making a youtube video did
you like the process back to Michael
from before do you like the process or
you only addicted to the results do you
like the process so make a youtube video
somebody asked you to go skiing say yeah
somebody asked you to help them with
their charity say yes say yes say yes si
si si si si yes as long as it fits with
your core value which you've just
identified because it's the most
important first step until you find a
thing that you want to go back to and
then with skills with practice with
training with development you can be
Michael Jordan of that industry but you
won't find it by sitting on the couch so
good luck I hope that helps next Michael
how do you find new mentors and then how
to ask or value first so how to find new
mentors is just exposing yourself to
opportunities so like the last question
saying yes I'd be looking online I'd be
look going to events I'd be looking at
who's on Instagram who's making YouTube
videos like this it's never been easier
to get access to mentors ever in human
history ever it's so easy how many
people are going live on snapchat or
going live on on Instagram or going live
on YouTube or have amas happening or
speaking on the conference there's so
much opportunity what I look at is try
to digest people's content and see who
resonates like maybe you watch my stuff
maybe you watched I Lopez maybe watch
Gary Vee you know maybe maybe Gary's a
guy who motivates you great like you
resonate with his content more than
anybody else amazing try to get on his
radar right same thing for me or grant
or whoever these people are when they go
live you want to be
their radar I would be sending DMS of
people making it personal trying to find
ways to add value this is the thing so
many people then message me on Instagram
so like next step they di me and they
say haven't I love for you to be my
mentor that's not gonna get you anywhere
say heaven can you please can you please
promote my new app it'd mean a lot to me
I'll make videos responding people say
dude I want you to win but you need to
add value first this strategy of
reaching out to however many people
you're reaching out to will not work
you're wasting your time I want you to
win you need to find a way to add value
first
that's how altom Utley you're gonna win
and so this morning on the bike somebody
writes back and says hey Evan how can I
add value to you that's not my job to
figure out that's your job to figure out
if you are going to a mentor who you
look up to a new respect and you want to
learn from your job is to then figure
out how can you help and so you can look
at what are they talking about what are
they launching what are they putting up
what do they care about go through their
content see what they're talking about
see what they're promoting see what
they're mentioning and then find a way
to help them today I've been talking
about how this this broadcast is brought
to you by my workshop in Toronto can you
help with that do you have ideas can you
promote it can you expose it can you
come and film it like can you do
something can you help me that's what
I'm working on right now I talked about
my books can you give it exposure can
you promote me can you help right do you
have ideas is there something else I'm
doing then you can lend some expertise
on that's your job to figure out and so
I respond and tell people because
moulton most people are going to ignore
you you could find the greatest
potential mentor in the world but if you
go in and say hey can you please mentor
me most people will not give you a
response if you say hey can you help
promote my thing people will just ignore
you and maybe block you and so the way
in is to be a known quantity to them if
there is if they're on social media
figure out where they're actually
responding like where are they
personally involved
where are they responding to people's
messages and be there and then be a
known quantity so if you want to get on
my radar
then I'm big I'm doing a lot
Instagram right now I'm on YouTube right
now be everywhere be what be everywhere
I am add value respond don't just say
great video add to the community help
the other people who are commenting as
well right
create some love I should be it I should
know who you are there's people in my
community who I know who they are
because they're everywhere they're there
everywhere that I am they're adding love
to the community and it's not a fake
relationship so be that and then when
you need an ask those people who I know
who have never met but I know they're
contributing if they ask me for
something I would help them now has to
be within reason
you know sponsor me to come to Canada
okay that's not happening right but can
you check out my app I check out their
app can you answer this one question for
me I'd answer their one question for
them right so be a known quantity next
Dave night thanks for what you do dollar
ninety-nine super chat Dave appreciate
it man almost buys me a coffee this is
like 225 but it's us this is Canadian so
it probably just buys me in the coffee
so thank you Dave Nick's coffees on you
another super chat from Yann I love it
man man I'm getting lots of coffees from
you guys really appreciate it two euros
I haven't any tips on how to overcome
fear of something huge one one is your
mindset so one is the mindset that
everything great happens on the opposite
side of fear that if you just stay in a
lane where you're not scared of anything
then you're not actually being you're
not fulfilling any potential that you
have as a human being right you're
living like a worm so everything great
happens on the other side of fear so
changing your mindset around fear as
that fear is a bad thing to fear will
allow me to create the life that I want
for myself my family of the community
whatever is inspiring you to I try to
make the future fear so big that it
makes the present fear smaller so what I
would do is if I wanted to make a
youtube video and I was scared to do it
I would imagine a life where every dream
that I had came true because I made this
YouTube video and if I don't do it then
I'm gonna live the rest of my life 50
years plus and regret that I didn't do
this and I make that fear so big and so
painful and so insanely you know
meaningful that now I have to do
something so it's that idea of like if
you have a hangnail on your on your
finger and somebody punches you in the
arm you don't feel the hangnail anymore
cuz you feel this pain and so I make I
just give myself a bigger pain of regret
which really drives me so then I have to
do that thing in front of me and then
the third thing I would say is just make
the fear smaller like whatever the big
scary thing is that you have to do find
the smallest possible way to get started
so that crazy idea of making a youtube
video you might say well I got to get an
editor I need light in the camera a
microphone bah bah bah bah bah this huge
scary thing now just start just like get
a phone and go right find the smallest
possible way so that the fear is not as
big because often once you get into it
the fear is not warranted it's just fear
of the unknown and so once you start you
build momentum to actually continue and
the fear really rapidly decreases and so
just finding whatever possible way you
need to to get started to build a little
bit of momentum the rest doesn't the
rest doesn't you happen on its own but
you're much more likely to follow
through and keep going if you just start
so that's what I got thank you thank you
again for the 2 euros definitely buys me
a coffee
I appreciate that yawn what do we got
Melissa thank you for all your work
Thank You Melissa I appreciate it
I miss you guys this is great did I do
this last week I feel like it maybe
didn't do last week I feel like it's
been way too long or it's just been a
crazy busy week Tracey Evan if you were
to lose everything you've worked for
today would you do the same thing all
over again or try something completely
different so that's an interesting
question one I wouldn't I wouldn't
change much probably so one of those
spend a lot of time even thinking about
that question I don't spend a lot of
time thinking reverse I spend all my
time thinking about right now and
present so what I change something or
not I don't know I know I can't control
that and so I don't I don't think about
I don't spend time thinking backwards
now if you gave me the opportunity to do
it sure if you brought me back to Evan
at 19 or Evan at 5 or ever net 22 or
Evan at 28 or whatever the
age was and I had the chance to kind of
whisper in my ear would I take it a
hundred percent I would take it I would
take it you know I'm I'm super
appreciative of my entire path I
genuinely really love my life right now
and every experience that I had leads me
to this life that I'm living right now
but if you gave me the chance to like be
there and whether it's negotiating
baseball cards for an extra five or ten
cents and and I whispering in my own ear
and say hey I think you can double that
you can you can charge 25 more cents you
know like believe it look it would
always we believe more believe in
yourself a little bit more believe
believe you can do it you can you can
push for that right I would do it of
course I would do it but I'm super
grateful where I am and spend zero time
thinking about this kind of stuff next
Michael should I build a personal brand
even if I'm doing IT so I'm a number
three I was at a secondary school should
I build a personal brand even I'm doing
IT so listen a personal brand can always
help you it just depends on your style I
think people like dealing with people
people like learning from people this is
the hardest thing for me to step out in
front of the camera put myself first
when I was doing my website I profiled
all those famous entrepreneurs I'm like
people kept asking but what's your story
why did you know what do what do why did
you start this why do you care and I
thought why do you care about me I'm
talking about Steve Jobs and Oprah and
all these big-name entrepreneurs I you
know I sold the business but I'm nothing
compared to what these guys have done
and what I understood was that my
journey really helps people make
progress in their life that by me
sharing my story is actually selfless
instead of selfish I think growing up
you know I got my parents on the wall
behind me you know maybe it's a
canadian-style
we don't have huge egos you know taught
to be humble and there's definitely a
good component of that that I think is
really helpful but ultimately if you
don't tell your story and you're afraid
to tell your story and you play to
humble you're actually limiting the
ability for somebody to make
breakthroughs in progress because your
journey and why you do the thing that
you do
is educational can be inspiring can move
people and so it's actually selfless to
tell your story and so that's what kind
of brought me out into the front that
realization do you have to do it no lots
of companies look at the list of
billionaires there's a bunch of people
who you've never heard of take away
inherited wealth because that's that
doesn't help but people who've built
their own thing from from the ground up
a bunch of them you've never heard of
they don't have personal brands so you
don't have to do it it's just an easy
way to build relationship with people
because people feel like they know me
even though I don't know them and so
people would much rather buy from a
person than a company but it's not the
only way to do it it has to you has to
play to your strengths and your desires
because if you build a personal brand
because you think it's only gonna help
with your your marketing but you hate
doing all the work you don't do it
you're gonna lose stop it right now
and focus on what your strengths are
next
Salima would you consider leaving the
mastermind
so I lead a mastermind in Toronto for
entrepreneurs who are between 300,000
and 3 million in revenue trying to get
to the next step I don't want it to be a
big part of what I do it's it's it's
more labor of love it takes a lot of my
time and I love helping people and that
in that capacity but really ultimately
what I want to do is have a big impact
so I wanted more than touch you know ten
people at a time in a deep way I want to
help millions of people so I will always
default to the bigger stuff to the
YouTube to the Instagram to the books
what I'm doing in Toronto is a test
right this workshop I have coming up in
May I want to take 15 thought leaders
people who want to do what I do
for their industry and and get my hooks
into them and help them like if these 15
people don't go off and start making
incredible things for their for their
channels for their brand for the for the
world I'm not doing this again I'm
putting so much love and effort to make
that the best three days of my time the
thing I value most is my time and so I'm
not spending three days doing something
else to spend that time with 15 people
if that doesn't lead to a massive change
in them I'm hoping that you know I know
when I get on Instagram live or on erm
answering questions for you my energy
can transfer for a little bit
whether you're still on fire for the
next hour or two great but a week later
is my energy still tapping into you
probably not I'm hoping that by spending
three full days with me or two depending
on the package that like it lasts longer
and I can actually do the work with you
while we're in the session together to
carry people through to build enough
momentum for you to win and if it
doesn't work then I'm gonna stop doing
it so people ask can you bring this to
London can you bring this to the states
can you bring this to Australia like I
don't know I'm gonna bring it to Toronto
again what am I gonna ever do this thing
again this is all an experiment and it's
really gonna depend on do the 15 people
who come make enough progress move the
needle enough that they are off having
an impact in the world because if it's
not I'm not doing it ever again so
that's my challenge always with the
mastermind with the small you know
one-on-one work I invest in some
entrepreneurs like Lilly who's in the
Chad and Alex I enjoy the one-on-one
work but I will never become only about
the one-on-one because I want to have a
big impact I want to I want to I want to
reach the entire planet thank you for
the question crazy-cool creations how do
you motivate yourself and stop
procrastinating so one is having goals
that mean something a lot of people's
goals suck you know a lot of people's
goals are so within their reach that
doesn't motivate them so you need to be
doing something that you know your
aspirations are interesting to the work
has to be has to be meaningful and
interesting I'm on here doing this live
chat because I like doing it because I
want to bring value not because I'm
tracking how many people watch and how
many people are commenting and all of
that is ultimately important but its
secondary to actually liking the work so
when you actually like the thing that
you're doing it's a lot easier to
motivate yourself if you hate what
you're doing you can only motivate
yourself for so long before you're just
gonna quit you will like you can you
can't keep forcing yourself to do
something you hate forever you will lose
so finding a way to enjoy the process
and not just that the end results and
then three we talked about it before the
routine just what do you do in the
morning to set yourself up to have an
amazing day most people wake up like an
accident most people have a terrible
morning routine most people wake up and
they fall into their
email and now they're just responding to
other people instead of actually doing
the thing that sets them up for success
and so I think doing those two things
will help you Michael as a teen as a
teen who doesn't make much money should
I invest thank you a suffering from
mental health but you've helped me so
much thanks I appreciate that man and
listen much more important the question
about investing is if you're suffering
from mental health and something like
this helps and then then surround
yourself with it constantly whether it's
me or or Steve or whoever write like
that if you found the thing that helps
you escape a mental health issue man
that is so powerful and now the trick is
to make that routine so if it's me it's
great because I got I got videos for
days for you to consume you got six
thousand videos to go through but but if
you grow tired of me you know great move
on to somebody else but if you found the
thing that helps you so important put
into your morning routine so you're
doing it daily I think for the investing
two schools of thoughts you know the
sooner you invest the more compound
interest starts building up the more
you'll be able to make you know save
that money for retirement and it becomes
something meaningful and to you know the
the biggest investment you can ever make
is in yourself and so if you know here's
the thing I hate spending money till I
make you money period I don't like
spending money on stuff until I'm making
some kind of money so I will always try
to find ways to bootstrap whatever it is
that I'm doing always always always
always like even now I need any new
thing I'm watching I'm doing I'm doing
it myself
I'm bootstrapping it up my Instagram is
all me right now if I figure out how to
really make it work then I'm giving it
to my team to help me but I do
everything myself or with friends or
like it's always bootstrapping until I
have a model so you don't need money to
make money because you're investing your
heart energy soul passion
resourcefulness to make it happen when
you start making some money then you
have a decision to make do I can I pour
money back into my business that it
lights this thing up it's gasoline on
the fire is pouring gasoline on on wood
it's not gonna do anything but if
there's a spark that can really explode
so pouring money into something
helped it blow up can really help and if
you don't know how how to pour that
money in to blow it up then you invest
it so I invested a lot when I was I'm
making 300 bucks a month and I was still
investing into into stocks because I
didn't know that everything would be a
gamble if I put money into my business I
didn't know that it would pay off so I
invested my heart energy hustle and
passion and put in the money into
investing and then as I got ideas and as
we as the company grew I said okay let's
put money back into the business because
it's see if I if I put a dollar in it's
gonna lead to ten and let's put $100 in
it's gonna lead to more and I thought
right it just makes sense I invest way
more now than I did before as I've made
more money and so I think it's just that
mantra whether you subscribe to it or
not of what I believe is don't spend
money till you make you money so when
you have money you have options if you
have if you have some kind of money
whether it's a hundred bucks a thousand
bucks 10k whatever it is you get to
decide if I do I have a not quite
guarantee but close to it that I've
proven my model that I can put into my
business and generate a return if it's I
have 10k it's all I have and I'm just
gonna test it on some startup I would
not do that I would put it into
investing and then use all my time to go
off and try to build the business if I
was making some money and I knew how if
I put some money into it it would take
off even more then I would do that so
depends on what your situation is where
your options are I only put money into
my business when I'm pretty confident
it's gonna have a big payoff guys it's
been an hour it's crazy man I'm really
flew by today I'm pumped for you I'm
pumped for this thank you so much as I
said this morning I was having a rough
energy day forcing myself to get in the
bike and get going and you guys brought
me back up I love it thank you so much
listen it's it's it's noon for me right
now whatever time it is for you there's
tons of time left in the day to make an
impact make something that your
grandkids gonna be proud of make
something that you're gonna be proud of
that you want to show your grandkids in
the world if there's been any energy
that I can give you today make sure you
don't just shut down this video and go
sit on the couch like do
thing with it the highest form of if
I've helped you in any way the highest
form of saying thank you is to pour that
into making something amazing for your
business in your life and so I hope you
do that today thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you next week